on Massachusetts Avenue in the Back Bay
neighborhood of Boston is the only place
where you can stand in the center of the
world and look into the past ever notice
how big Greenland is on most maps look
at this look at how big Greenland is
that is insane
that's because maps have a problem when
you take a sphere like the globe and you
mash it onto a flat surface things get a
little bit wonky and even looking at a
globe as the countries fade away from
you they change in size and perspective
now if you really really want to get a
perfect view of what the world looks
like there's only one place for you and
that is the map area sitting in the Mary
Baker Eddy library is a three-story
stained-glass globe with a walkway
running from the Pacific Ocean to the
Indian Ocean going straight through it
and when you walk out into the center
and you look at the 600-plus
stained glass panels showing you the
world in perfect relative scale things
look crazy Africa is huge North America
and Europe are jammed way up at the top
you have to Crane your neck way back
just to see them
Greenland of course is much smaller and
New Zealand is floating out in the
middle of nowhere
of course hopefully you only care about
the relative size of countries in 1935
because well the scale is all correct
the geography is decidedly out of date
in 1930 Boston architecture Lindsey
Churchill was hired to design the
headquarters of the Christian Science
publishing house and he had seen the
giant globe in the New York Daily News
building but he wanted to do one better
in 1932 he began building the map area
it is a place to be immersed in 360
degrees by a beautiful stained-glass map
you really get to see the world as it
was in 1934 I'm saying
the center of the world looking out at
all of the countries that existed in
1935 colonialism is in full effect
Africa is divided into huge swaths among
the European powers go look for
Southeast Asia it's not there instead
you'll find French Indochina and there
are a bunch of countries with strange
and unfamiliar names never still
Transjordan and a Baluchistan remembers
the miriam has another unusual quality
it is an incredible Whispering Gallery
people having a quiet conversation in
India can be heard loud and clear in
Mexico and if you go and stand in the
center you will hear yourself in
surround sound also sounds it does
incredibly the acoustics are constantly
being bounced back to you so you hear
your own voice for to you and a
half a second later you want this is
like listening to your own voice not so
great it's cool it's really cool
subscribe here and watch more videos
here also everyone knows that the best
map projection is Dymaxion that is just
a true fact go Bucky